everydays dates white my cousin don't
love me
natalie is saying that romantic comedies
are about all those maybes allows it to
terrible pop songs I think people would
have an easier time seeing you if you
were a little more open okay I have
because there's a scene in this movie
where there's a date in an ice cream
parlor so I have what's called the ice
cream personality test tell me your
favourite ice cream and I'll tell you
what that says about your personality
what is your favorite ice cream mint
chocolate chip
ooooouch means your argumentative well I
need to stop you right stubborn though
and a planner what about you Priyanka
cookies-and-cream it's not on my list
can we make what is what I was gonna say
cookie dough what's the second favorite
I'll give you another I was gonna say
let go like a rocky road rocky road
you're aristocratic and you like the
finer things in life
chocolate means you're the life of the
party you're a risk-taker and you get
bored easily oh my gosh you're impulsive
you're jazzy and you have a good when
you do a kiss in the movie like an
onscreen kiss yes I've been told that
you have to stick out your lips further
and you have to turn your head in a
weird way and it's not really like real
kissing like you know like you can't
really give it your best shot you have
to turn your head in ways that you might
not normally leave because they're
trying to get the camera around ya but
you don't really have to stick your lips
I've definitely sometimes gone for
comedic kisses yeah we won best kiss one
yeah we do
yeah there's something about you going
on a truffled date for Valentine's Day
with Liam and Miley but since this is
the perfect trouble if you guys could
come up with the best Valentine's Day
and you're gonna go together what are
you guys gonna do I feel like we would
buy tickets to isn't it romantic that's
a good idea for everyone should know one
what's your emergency someone's broken
into my apartment and they've taken
everything and replace it all with much
nicer stuff so your emergency is that
your apartment is too big and you have
every shoe you could ever want yeah
exactly that's what I yeah okay off the
pretty woman sure you look like you
drank the kool-aid after directing this
film you look like you fully embrace
romance have you Hey yes what were you
already already a romantic and that's
hence you directed this film I was a
romantic yeah and I tried to fill the
set with as much romance as I could real
couples were always around us and like I
I'm from New York the couple that
introduced my parents to each other is
in the movie are you serious Central
Park in the scene where she's getting
the Heimlich as Joan and Geoffrey you
introduced my parents for each other
thirty years ago and the couple in
Washington Square Park that rebel and
Adam bump into it's a real couple I
found on the street and and and I myself
had just gotten out of a relationship so
I was particularly heartbroken no I'm
really sad and so trying to just get
feeling on this set Wow people in the
film in the last couple of months and
three and three couples got together on
set that's amazing yeah so I know Liam
there's like the whole musical number
and Liam was not exactly thrilled about
the fact that he had to dance cuz he
thinks he's a bad dancer did you notice
there's a move that I want to coin the
Liam you know how there's like the
sprinkler
where he holds his jacket collar you can
demonstrate if you want does he go what
does he do he does like he goes like
this yes that's it no does this that's
the so did he do that or was that a
choreographer or how did that all come
about was that just his own no it's fine
he didn't he didn't know what to do with
his hands he didn't know what to do with
his arms he didn't know where that he
was like a Frankenstein with the arm he
was and the choreographer and he was
asking he said what do I where do I do I
go like this what do I do
when the choreographer was like just put
him on your lapels and used to use your
jacket and he was like yeah that's good
and that became his goat and it's also
it is John Travolta and there's a bit of
grease action going on in there too so
yeah so this is rebel trapped rebels
characters trapped in a rom-com if you
yourself I'm sure you're a movie fanatic
fan if you would could be trapped in any
movie in history what movie would you
like to be trapped in I'd have a better
answer for this question no why would
you matter wasn't original let me ask
you a different one man know they say
what rom-com I don't know well I'm not
I'm giving you the whole spectrum
what movie don't want to be oh you know
it would be good big night because that
Italian food what John we're just the
prison scene of Goodfellas cuz the
Italian food I'm so hungry
oh my gosh so talk to me about rebel she
you know she's producing this movie this
is her first big I know she's produced
before but her first feature film
producing is she a boss on set yeah
she's great on said actually she's
really more of a partner on set she
she's packed she was passionate about
this movie because I think it was a lot
her experience as a young woman growing
up and seeing these movies and being
like this is [ __ ] don't know what
you're talking about
no I do I raise that now you'll bleep me
out we're online [ __ ] this isn't
real and so so we were really in it
together especially in the preparation
of you know what do we want it to feel
like what do we want to be saying with
this movie what's that last moment gonna
be like you know where you finally feel
whole and accepting of yourself you know
but she was also she's an amazing
comedic mind and so always you know she
had like a binder filled with jokes that
she wouldn't show me so then on set she
would try something and I got to be the
first audience of the movie you know ha
ha ha oh no that one not that oh that's
so good you do that you know I mean so
it was really exciting to watch it come
alive through her they played a joke on
you too didn't they the last days that
wasn't funny what did they do you know
the last day on set we were in the
ice-cream shop which was um one of my
favorite scenes in the film of rebel and
Liam and this beautiful ice-cream shop
on their date and that's an ice-cream
shop from my childhood in Queens that I
used to go to all the time when I would
sit there and be like one of these days
I'm gonna make a movie in this place and
so I got to make it really a beautiful
scene and right as we were about to
begin shooting it someone told me that
the actors it was late at night and
there's a last day and they just decided
to go home we don't need this scene you
don't need it we did the whole movie and
to go home and it broke my heart because
it was like my dream coming true when
they tell the story I don't know if they
know that they think it was so funny to
play a prank on me but it was crushing
and and I freaked out and I how could
you let them leave and all this and but
they actually were just hiding next door
in a movie theater that was next door to
the ice cream shop and but I walked in
and then they jumped out from behind a
poster
you